the twelve boys and their soccer coach
who spent more than two weeks trapped in
a cave in Thailand are expected to go
home this week newly released photos
show the boys in the hospital this
morning they can be seen hugging the
Thai Navy medic who took care of them in
the cave and a Warner is in Chiang Rai
Thailand with the latest on their
conditions and a good morning good
morning health officials say the boys
are doing well here some who lost as
much as 11 pounds are starting to gain
that weight back meanwhile their parents
were back at the cave today for a
ceremony volunteers along with the
families gathered at the cave in
Thailand Monday where the 12 boys and
their soccer coach were rescued after
being trapped for more than two weeks
the cave has been closed ever since the
last boy was pulled out there are plans
to make it into an interactive museum
but for now everyone is just grateful to
pay their respects a memorial ceremony
was also held for the former Thai Navy
SEAL who died during the rescue mission
new photos show the 12 Thai boys paying
tribute to the seal from their hospital
room the boys bowed their heads as they
surrounded a drawing of the diver some
later wiped away tears earlier the
government released these video clips of
the boys they said they were feeling
well and thanked their rescuers Thai
officials hope the entire group will go
home by Thursday
well the parents actually went into the
cave for the first time this afternoon
since the boys have been rescued one
father told us it was spooky for him
because he had been preparing himself
for the idea that his son might not
emerge from that cave alive Gail
all right Anna Werner thank you very
much would you guys want to go in the
cave I think I would I think I would
want to say well to understand what the
experience they had been they were
really now that no okay not you so watch
this far with the exception of the death
of that see oh I'm so glad they're okay
thank you Anna